comedy's whole thing is that it's well a
comedy it's funny but for all the
creative genius and careful planning
that goes into crafting a comedy classic
filmmakers simply can't plan for the
happy little accidents I guess caught on
film
throwing the shooting of a movie
fortunately those moments happen all the
time and the best ones are usually even
funnier than the movies that's born them
you like go watches here
here are some bloopers that should have
made at the final cut super bad a whole
new generation got its very own iconic
nerd in Superbad he came in the form of
McLovin played by Christopher
mintz-plasse while he holds his own was
Jonah Hill and Michael Cera one thing he
couldn't hold his own with was a fee
what the B man grow a set then when
they're about to do another take Jonah
Hill can't resist messing with him one
more time it's right there dude all
right yeah that's what friends are for
right
guardians of the galaxy one of the
funniest entries in the MCU guardians of
the galaxy is hilarious in large part
because of Chris Pratt's casting a
star-lord Pratt was known to improv on
set and some of his on the fly bid
stayed in the final cut of guardians and
yet despite all the comedy that wound up
on screen
somehow the Bluebird of Pratt's maniacal
fake laughter is just as funny as any
line of dialogue that took weeks to fine
tune
[Applause]
and command to an endlessly quotable
comedy classic anchorman follows the
absurd exploits of the 1970s San Diego
news team struggling to survive a
changing world in 2013 the cast returned
for a sequel which finals a Channel 4
News team joining an upstart cable news
network in 1980 little else has changed
particularly Brian Fantana
the sex-obsessed ladies man portrayed by
Paul Rudd in the first movie he shows
off his collection of toxic colognes
60% of the time it works every time that
doesn't make sense in the sequel he
updates the gag by unveiling his condom
collection and the blooper reel shows
that he had plenty of jokes in the
pipeline if he could get them out
without laughing
PTP electioneer and all over your lady
gon give her a Pepsi that's horrible
stay classy Fontana The Hangover Part 3
like many film franchises the hangover
franchise suffered from diminishing
returns the first film from 2009 it
captured lightning in a bottle and the
filmmakers went back to the same premise
two more times in the first movie they
went to Las Vegas in the second one they
hits Bangkok and in The Hangover Part 3
the Wolfpack heads back to Sin City so I
think it's happened again but none of
that's really important because when
Zach Galifianakis is part of a cast it
doesn't matter what the plot is either
one man snack demanding Wolfpack boot in
the film and on the gag reel either food
belly now mother fish sticks tater tots
now please mother hush puppies in Oreo
smoothie now please step with us Will
Ferrell and john c reilly proved they
were among the best comedy duo's of all
time and Step Brothers playing stunted
adult man children forced to get along
when their coddling parents marry each
other but things to agile comic minds on
the set together day after day was bound
to lead to some improvisation and
cracking up and wrestling
oh say yourself Deadpool it was the
rolled Ryan Reynolds was born to play a
crude sarcastic action hero with
absolutely no filter
oh poor wife but a casting choice that
worked just as well with TJ Miller as
wade Wilson's best friend and bartender
weasel Miller is a veteran stand-up
comic and the star of HBO's Silicon
Valley so it's no surprise that when he
sat down to split board jokes about Wade
Bolton's new face but things got a
little weird you look like an avocado
had sex with an older more disgusting
avocado in the blooper reel weasel just
keeps the jokes coming
looks like somebody turn your face
inside out and just left it like that
but then you got in a house fire do you
look like the inside of other people
called you look like a house fire was in
another house fire
hush trainwreck it seems like whenever a
big time pro wrestler moves into acting
a people are genuinely shocked by their
abilities but years and years of
performing in character the crowd
certainly trains them for the silver
screen case in point John Cena who had
to act alongside comedian Amy Schumer in
trainwreck
Cena plays an enthusiastic romantic
partner to Schumer's character and he's
obviously committed to the path so
committed that he makes a pro comic like
Amy Schumer crack up non-starter in
their sex scene maybe we can do it as a
couple like I'll be your coach I don't
want you to be like Austin Powers in
Goldmember early in Beyonce's rise to
world domination
she makes the maximum with a music
career which included playing undercover
spy foxy Cleopatra in Mike Myers third
Austin Powers outing Beyonce's beauty
played well on-screen opposite Austin
Powers rakish charm do I make you horny
baby do I do I make you Randy she also
serves an important role as a straight
character for powers warranty humor a
fox displayed all too well in these
outtakes some I don't know I can make my
nipples wink say what kangaroos make me
horny
from time to time my nipples will
lactate thanks for watching click the
loofah icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your nothing
[Music]